it's kind of just a fun thing that you
can do in this moment when we're all
kind of desperate for fun things and I
mean hey everyone I'm here with Michael
waters one of our staff writers welcome
Michael hi
so we're I'm excited about a story
Michael found this week is about
cardboard cutout fans and in a moment
we're like lots of people are returning
to business as normal sports leagues are
finally starting to announce plans and
starting to play games again but mostly
in empty stadiums and Michael's got an
interesting story about how they're
going to cope with the loss of ticket
revenue and also try to sort of add some
color to the stadium's on TV that they
show their game son tell us a little
about how you found the story Michael
yeah so I think like a lot of people I
came across a few anecdotal cases of
different sports teams in Germany in
South Korea putting up cardboard fans in
order to fill the stadiums and like my
immediate question was who are the
people who are actually supplying these
cardboard fans and why and who's buying
them and that leads me down a very long
journey through the world of cardboard
fans and I'm not sure if everyone's
familiar but the way the model of this
works is basically that a fan of a
sports team will buy will take a photo
of themselves and then submit it to the
team and where the team does is they'll
partner with a startup company to print
out your photo on cardboard and then put
you up in the stands and it's like a
photo from your torso up so you have
these very funny-looking cardboard
cutouts of people like smiling or
cheering just kind of like frozen in
different stadium seats throughout the
world and what I realized as I started
reporting this is that I kind of
expected this to be like a one-off
novelty I assume that just a few sports
stadiums would actually be doing this
but it's actually spreading throughout
much of the world lots of major teams
and a lot of small
teams in particular are getting in on
this and there they're about like four
or five different companies throughout
the world especially in the UK that are
basically the brains behind creating
cardboard fans and they're partnering
with different especially like smaller
teams to print the fans to create like
an online portal and people are buying
them and they're so far most of the like
most of the cardboard fans that exists
are based outside of the US especially
in England's premier league they have a
number of teams there that are doing
cardboard fans but so far there's one
soccer team in Auckland called the
Oakland roots that is in the process of
rolling out their cardboard fans system
and they're partnering with a UK company
to do that and the way that they're
approaching this for instance is partly
to recoup revenue but it's also a way to
sort of showcase their community of fans
in this moment when everyone is a part
and so they're a pretty small team they
have a stadium of like five or six
thousand people that usually sold out
pre-pandemic and their aim right now and
they just launched this project last
week is to start filling up their
preseason and their regular season games
with that fan community from Auckland
that kind of made them possible the
first place and so they're even donating
like a portion of the profits to local
racial justice causes and when the
cardboard fans are all over they're
gonna try to create a collage of all the
different thousands of people who
submitted photos of themselves and had
themselves printed on cardboard and try
to put that up around the city is sort
of this like odd perhaps representation
of this moment but also just of the
community of people who kind of showed
up and got through it very cool
no the Oakland roots is the name of this
team and they're a minor league soccer
team that was this story that stood out
to me the most in your piece just
because if as you said that it's sort of
representative of the local community of
people that have rallied behind this for
this team so what's in it for the fan is
it basically just
our way of extending a little bit of
help to the team in this time it's
partly about supporting your favorite
team but I also think that in a lot of
cases these cardboard cutouts are gonna
be placed in TV viewable seats and I
could get to this later but whether you
actually see yourself on TV is kind of
difficult but the idea is I mean if
you've ever gone to a sports game in
general I think a lot of people will go
back and watch the highlight reel to see
if they can see themselves I am NOT a
sports person but when I was a kid I
went to Fenway Park in Boston a few
times and like I would always watch ESPN
the next day and I would just try to get
a gun to myself and I task like one of
my parents or someone who didn't show up
with like trying to find me on TV and so
this is like this is more of a guarantee
that you'll actually see yourself
because not all the stadium seats are
gonna be filled with cardboard cutouts
and so the cardboard cutters that do
exist are gonna be prioritized in TV
viewable seats in a lot of cases I'm
obviously a very seemed a team and yeah
but I did mention that whether you
actually find yourself as difficult
because um a lot of cases you're not
like the companies that are doing
cardboard fans are not going to send you
individual photos so it is up to you to
seek yourself out on TV and to watch a
stream but I do think I do think an
element of this is definitely we want to
support our team but it's also I mean
it's also kind of just a way to connect
more broadly with the act like the
participation of sports and of being a
sports fan and it's kind of just a fun
thing that you can do in this moment
when we're all kind of desperate for fun
things and I mean I like looked around
and talked to some people and so for
instance there's like a woman in
Australia who submitted a cardboard
cutout of her dog for a rugby game
recently and then I also spoke to a man
in the UK who sent a photo of his late
father who was a big fan of one of these
teams in order to have him be on the
broadcast and so there's definitely an
element of like haha
why not but there's also I mean really
real sentimental value and this for a
lot of people very cool well I'm gonna
let you go because in about a half an
hour we were gonna tune into a British
soccer game where you have bought a
cardboard cutout of your father who's
not a fan of this team but just as part
of the process of importing this you're
gonna see if you can find him on this
televised broadcast right yes yes I'm
not optimistic about this at all but
obviously as a journalist I have to go
through with this work and I have to
watch this game and try to find him and
the photo I took of my dad he has a
little sign that says the hustle on it
which is literally just printer paper
that I printed out but it would be
really cool if I could got a screenshot
of that so if any of you happen to watch
this game and you see a 67 year old man
holding bustled please let me know
that's good alright we'll see if we can
find him and if that anecdote makes it
into the story it might actually end up
getting cut in a fantasy
alright thanks Michael thank you
you
[Music]